yes tonight is of course a very talented
actress who's appeared in numerous films
and TV shows including Mary Poppins
returns the newsroom and match point now
you can see our in the film relic which
is available on demand I am thrilled
she's joining me
please welcome Emily Mortimer hi Emily
how are you I'm very happy to see you um
you know let's first explain where you
are are you outside of London somewhere
are you in a rural area in England I'm
in a rural area in England yes okay I
like that you're saying that as if you
really don't want me to know exactly
where you are because you think I'm
creepy that's the way you said that in
the continental England which includes
Scotland okay it was the way you phrase
the question you said it like it was
slightly sort of sinister where I might
be that's I think that's just how I come
across to women and I apologize outside
bath okay is that is that from Chaucer I
don't they on their way to bath or
they're coming back from Africa the wife
or thought there's a wife a father okay
I knew I knew something was going on
with bath there was a historical
reference that I had to make let me I
thank you that's the reason I did it I
want to ask you first of all I want to
point out that I did an interview with
someone on a podcast recently who was in
England and I could see them it was a
zoom call and we were chatting and it
was in the morning for me and it went
early in the in the in the zoom call
this woman picked up a glass of wine and
took a big and I thought oh my god she's
an alcoholic
I forgot that she lists it's night time
for you in fact I'm not a girl no I'm
not gonna show you what I've got beneath
the the computer screen but there's the
whole
there's a ball basically at my feet well
feel free to drink I want everyone to be
relaxed especially you and and so just
you know it's fine it's fine if you
drink because I will tell all my viewers
that you are in London and it's it's the
drinking hour where you are you're a
drink yes exactly exactly don't tell
them I'm actually in Palm Springs and
they and that you have a rift Palm
Springs 8 o'clock a.m. and everyone's
gonna think you have a big problem who
are you staying with right now are you
staying with family
well yes I came I came to see my mom and
my my sister who are here I'm not
actually in the same house as them one
but yes I came to see my mum my
chain-smoking mother who is assuring me
that she's protecting herself from
coronavirus with the smoking which she
read on some dark web protects you
she thought she's gone from smoking a
pack of the day to now she's up to
probably two packs because she's
convinced it's um it's saving her life
and and she's read somewhere that in
France they even put nicotine patches on
Korona patients which I actually believe
I think it seems very French but I'm not
sure that she's I don't know whether her
theory is true and I keep saying to her
mom this is really worrying can you
please stop smoking and she says darling
her answer is darling I don't have a dry
cough I've got a very fruity cough
indeed which indeed she does this is let
me jump in here and just all due respect
to your mom this is terrible advice for
anybody out there you do not want to be
smoking and combat coronavirus there's
no evidence that I mean listen I don't
want to get into a fight with your mom
but she says it's who always wants to be
smoking coronavirus coronavirus is that
right yes she's just upped it
she's just upped it a lot and with and
and now she's she feels that she
totally within her rights to close all
the doors and all the windows and you
know expose us to sort of second-degree
lung cancer while she protects her own
health by chains okay now I know you
have kids how are your kids doing with
the quarantine in isolation are they
okay
they've been really good and they've
been very brave and much more kind of
stoic in a way than anyone else but
there are the odd moments of lapses
where me and my husband were in there
we're in I think we were upstairs and
they were downstairs at one point in the
midst of it all and we heard our
daughter who's 10 say very loudly to our
son who's 16 can you stop farting in my
face I'm just trying to survive here
which I felt just about summed up the
experience I would prefer your mom's
cigarette smoke sorry to look really
really good to me you know a lot of
people are worried about flying these
days and it's turning out that actually
a lot of the airlines are being very
good it can be quite safe to to fly
because of all the precautions they're
taking with keeping people separated and
being extra careful but I know that you
have a fear of flying even when there is
no coronavirus you've always been afraid
to fly is that right yes I'm terrified
of flying which is a big handicap given
that I fly all the time from my job I
mean many times a year and no it's
dreadful like I dunno what to do about
it and it's got me terrible sort of
pickles in the past because I end up
getting very confessional on airplanes
thinking that I'm definitely plummeting
to my doom and I need to kind of offload
myself of all my deepest darkest secrets
and and then I don't die and and I've
told some perfect stranger everything
about myself and I did it once on a
flight to yell to I was doing um I was
doing a job in in yalta in the the
ex-soviet Union and and I was sitting
next to a very nice man
and I you know those flights are
terrifying that there there it was an
Aeroflot internal flight which you're
told that sort of you know people that
work for embassies and things are banned
from going on because I think on average
about 20 people a week die on them
because they're mainly driven by very
drunk ex equivalent of RAF Russian
pilots who get bored and sort of do
loop-de-loops drunk and then crash and
and there were literally several
laughing but if a pilot decides to do a
loop-de-loop it's hard not to giggle a
little bit apart from when you're on the
plane anyway and so I got on this plane
and there were literally sort of
newspapers stuffing up the windows and
kind of there was like three the safety
precautions were three parachutes that
was sort of dotted around various places
in the airplane and I just knew I was
gonna die so I i offloaded all my really
sort of were secrets that there's very
nice gentleman who was sitting next to
me
and then realized that he went in fact
in the show that i was about to go and
film this very sweet man knowing
everything about me and and and winking
knowingly whenever i sort of walked into
the bar and i think oh my god you early
yeah your secret's safe with me
well guess what I contacted that man in
he toke thing and I want to ask you
about it now wouldn't that be a fun turn
of events yes you studied acting in
Russia didn't you I did I did well I
didn't really I studied Russian at
University in England and then I did a
year abroad as a sort of practice year
but I didn't learn anything cuz I went
to drama school in in Moscow and I just
got a huge crush on the guy that was
teaching me Russian and gamma oh that's
classic for people to get a crush on
their instructor you know especially
when you're young and you're in a
foreign country what was this guy like
was he very commanding you know sir
depressive guy he was cool Dmitri gurus
neat
and he was well in my mind's eye he was
all of those things but I don't know I
think love is blind maybe I don't know
I'm sure he was all of those things but
I just was obsessed by him and I didn't
get pickup any knowledge either of
acting or of how to speak Russian but I
did finally get him back to my apartment
for dinner
with you know I staged this whole thing
with the other students that had been on
my course and I made this delicious
dinner for everybody and he did lo and
behold more carrot onto the balcony and
start sort of looking up at the moon and
talking about moon and and quite
seemingly quite sort of romantic terms
but I thought she was so drunk on vodka
because I was so excited that he had him
in my house that um I started vomiting
silently behind him into my I knew I was
gonna be sick but I didn't want to leave
so I would simply sit quietly into my
hands behind him a week notice he was so
engrossed as as in his he was waxing so
lyrical at the moon that he didn't have
failed to notice me vomiting behind them
and I can't really remember how it
played out but it's sort of I think I
went off him
that he didn't notice that he was so
self-involved he didn't notice that's
the least romantic story I've ever heard
you are you're Wow okay I like that you
discreetly threw up which is a very hard
thing in a very ladylike fashion first
of all I keep getting distracted by your
background because you say that you're
in sort of a rural part of England and
it looks like you're on the set of a
quaint Agatha Christie murder man you
know what I mean I just keep it looks
like soon they're gonna gather you all
in the room that you're in and try and
figure out who the murderer is it's
actually it's actually a backdrop it's
not real behind it is Palm Springs where
I really am and it's 8:00 in the morning
and I'm drunk on whisky okay all right
yeah
it's I'm staying at a friend of Mines
house and it is really beautiful and I
do feel a little bit like I'm in and I
could do something yeah I'm just
suggesting that you might want to murder
someone well just cuz it's the perfect
place to do it I agree I agree you know
I was thinking about you've done I want
to talk about relative but I was just
thinking today about you've done so much
good work and you've shown up in in so
many good projects and I was trying to
think of the first time I saw you and
was like who's that I remembered you had
a big break in
was it Notting Hill was that it was that
one of your early roles that you were in
yeah it was really one of my first jobs
and I I was so delighted because I got
this part and um you know it was a small
part but I was called the perfect girl
that was my character type that was my
name I didn't actually have a name I was
just the perfect girl I was never an
actor but I did go to one audition once
for something for I think it was the
Henson Company or something there was
some show that they were looking for and
they said we have a role you'd be
perfect for and they sent over sides and
there were two characters and they
didn't tell me which one was who for who
and the two characters were the hunk and
the geek and I remembered reading the
description of the hunk and then I
remembered reading the description of
the geek and was like this tall gangly
goofball isn't exactly a winner with
women but he's such he's so silly that
no one takes him seriously and I went oh
okay I get it
I'm not gone I I once had a part where
they they say I only had like a couple
of lines I was playing a publicist again
I didn't have a name I was just the
publicist I had a couple of lines and
then they said and I was like okay with
us fine I'll I'll do the part and then
they they they rung up all excited in my
agent saying they've added to your part
there's some more you know it's if
there's another whole scene and I was
like oh god my I flipped through
desperately trying to find the rest of
the park but I couldn't see that we're
finally in the sort of small print scene
description I found one line that said
the publicist is hog-tied and g'nite in
the court
that's it that was the great new
addition to my role hey
well hey no lines to learn so you have
that going for you now I want to talk to
you about relic this is a scary movie
it's a great it's a great mood piece and
it's it one of the things that is I
would think difficult for an actor and
your terrific actor but I would think it
would call for you to be you're
frightened almost all the time and I
would think that's not easy as an actor
it's very difficult now it's very
difficult I mean I find it very easy to
be scared in life I'm all often scared
in life but um but to sustain you know
and you can manufacture it from to a
degree but to sustain that level of fear
for sort of four weeks straight
is um it's quite exhausting and quaint
pressings yep just keep conjuring up all
these terrible sort of thoughts and
feelings what kind of things are you
conjuring up like I've you know I've got
a zoom in cross across the pond with
Conan O'Brien that kind of rock terror
it is clear actually chat shows are one
of my biggest fear along with rats and
fear flying
um I have a preternatural terror of chat
shows and I do think of them when I'm
running down corridors in horror films I
could see yeah I could see you I see the
association between going on it talking
to a talk show host and encountering a
rat
I'm surprised you say that because I was
talking to someone today and I told them
that that I was gonna be talking to you
you're one of my favorite people to talk
to you because you're so natural you're
always yourself and you're always funny
and entertaining so I don't I don't
imagine you of all people getting
worried before you do something like
this well you know what I think those
are the reason that maybe if I am good
to talk to is because I'm so sort of
desperate to please that I will sell my
grandmother basically for a joke and so
that makes me sometimes quite a good
subject but it often leaves me feeling
slightly Hollow and sort of ashamed
afterwards no
I speak to you ever you made me feel
good about terrible things I reveal
about myself you know why I think that's
true I think it's true because you and I
are kindred spirits I will sell anybody
down the river if it's gonna get me a
laugh the only difference is I don't
feel horrible afterwards you're a better
person than I am that you have that
feeling afterwards I am a true sociopath
big laugh I did I make it that often
there at the expense of myself which is
mostly fine but there are moments when
it's like oh I shouldn't have done that
I've got a bit far this time I did that
once with her I'm now gonna do it again
but I feel like I'm older now I can I
can handle it yep when I was in my 20s
and I was being interviewed by a woman
for The Observer newspaper which is like
a very serious of the broadsheets
it's like the New York Times on Sunday
and I was desperately selling my
grandmother and everyone else I know
because she was one of those Janice that
was sitting with her pen hovered above
her paper not touching pens paper sort
of waiting for you to say something
interesting and then you get into panic
you more and more stuff comes out
waiting for the pen to start the paper
and I I started telling her a story even
as I began the story I was thinking oh
um why am I doing this but basically I
can't really remember the story but I
know that the punchline was ended with
me peeing it myself in a car with my
sister I got to the end of the story and
she didn't laugh not and her pen didn't
hit the paper and she went she was about
was about three seconds of horrified
silence after which she said um out of
respect for you Emily I shall never
repeat that story that's the kind of
thing you can channel when you need to
be scared in wait are you laughing at my
acting this is my my acting this is me
acting scared
that's it it's unlike us I'm a silent
film star I don't have your hair is
looking terrified as you do that yeah my
hair is I haven't cut it
since the quarantine and sometimes I
just let it go but sometimes when I'm
talking to you know a guest that I am
very excited to talk to I make the
mistake of blow-drying it before I come
on and it puffs up in this humid weather
and it becomes this thing and then you
know it it's ridiculous and I'm sure
it's just terrifying
and also it's structurally unsound yes a
clip from relic your character I mean
you feel free to set it up but your
character has come back to a house yes
living you know what happened to your
mother
and there's you're looking for clues and
some eerie palpably sort of scary tense
things are happening that are giving you
a bad feeling about it all is that a
fair summation it's a beautiful
summation you know let's take a look at
this clip from relic
what was that okay dono
and I also want to make sure that I
mentioned don't look deeper yes would be
yes donut deeper on kwibi that's coming
out very imminently and it's later this
month yes thank you I love that I know
more about your career than you do going
to find out I'm going to find out where
this house is not for any nefarious
purposes the worst thing I'll do is
leave some scones at your door and then
run away like an elf
that's the worst it still find it creepy
I think okay and I love talking to you I
really do this is a and yeah I and I
look forward to seeing you in person
when all of this madness ends yes me too
and my mother's right and we can we'll
all be chain-smoking I think listen if
you if we get one piece of information
out of this it's that or two pieces of
information out of this interview
it's that relic is is out there right
now and that possibly according to your
mother
chain-smoking is the best way to defeat
kovat they're gonna take that clip and
run that everywhere and you'll be
arrested I think with probably within
the hour
all right relic is playing in drive-ins
that's so cool
select theaters and available on video
on demand and don't look deeper is
streaming on kwibi starting July 27th
thank you so much for joining
yeah and stay safe and I think you can
have a drink now because it's very late
where you are I'm gonna have a huge
drink I'm gonna gloat it's only it's
just about noon here and that's when I
get to start so I'm gonna go yeah I do
have a great night and thank
you very much take care here's the
awkward sign-off where we both look for
the back very unattractive look for me
huh huh bye-bye